bigbrother season 18 kicks off one week
from today on CBS our reality show
expert Bryce sander meant the new
contestants and a few of them seem to
think this is a dating show because of
all those past look up she is among
those lining up for a Big Brother show
manses preschool teacher Zakia showmance
Azhar on the test I'm looking for a show
man that would be great like a Rachel
and Brendan I'm Jordan and Jeff you know
Zakia and whoever mr. sexy you know that
would be great
for gym manager Victor no this is
strategy I'm open to a showmance
especially if it helps my game but just
got to keep my eye on the 500,000 that's
why I'm here
Cory the baseball coach hopes to get
past second base so there may be a
showmance in your future uh there might
be if it's my game you can forget it but
you know it's definitely possibility but
form a student brontë a showmance
doesn't add on numbers girl I look at
the statistics and a lot of showing up
this just make you an easy target so my
goal is to fuel other show-me ounces
I'll be like girl do you see the way
that guy looked at you he said we're
cool I believed you remember last
season's master manipulator Vanessa she
has a sister competing now 32 year old
teacher Tiffany I know I sound a lot
like her a lot of people told me that
and I can hear it myself so if by chance
it comes out you know I'm gonna own up
to it and Kody the house stud from two
seasons ago has a brother Pauly in it to
win what invite he's has he given you he
told me to dial back personality was
like the first first couple weeks
don't be the crazy personality the first
couple weeks otherwise you're going home